I'd like to extend a personal invitation
to you an invitation to murder if you
were to assign knives out homework to us
like we have to watch like three things
before we go watching this let's not
call it homework that doesn't sound fun
how about I give you three awesome
movies that you're gonna love that will
not feel like homework first of all
everyone needs to track down and see a
movie called the last of Sheila this is
a crazy 1970s movie that was written by
Stephen Sondheim and Anthony Perkins and
it's about a bunch of rich people who
get together on a yacht for a murder
game where like the host has like
assigned everybody it's like a murder
mystery party and of course it goes
horribly wrong and someone actually dies
it is so funky and so 70s and so cool
the cast is awesome last of Sheila last
of Sheila's number one number two I'm
trying to pick between two in my head
right now okay let's go with death on
the Nile the original 19 late 70s death
on the Nile Peter used enough as Poirot
he's hilarious
the cast again it's like an all-star
cast oh it's like Betty Davis is
freaking in it
mia farrow is amazing in it she plays
like the lead in it David Niven is it's
just like it's phenomenal so much fun
death on the Nile and number three you
know I've been rewatching a ton of
recently Tommy
Columbo Oh so if you've never seen the
original Columbo it's on I think it's
not I think a bunch of them are on
Amazon Prime right now I have not go
back and watch there is so much fun and
they're so good there's there's one
called murder by the book which Steven
Spielberg directed which is one of the
first ones that's really fun to watch
but they're all fantastic and if you're
a fan of seventies actors it's also they
got like the most fun people to cut like
Dick Van Dyke came in he's a 70s actor
but Dick Van Dyke plays the murderer and
one of them like that's the level of
like people that were getting to come
like do these crimes yeah so track down
some call them but this is there you
have it there's your non homework it's
not homework it's recommendation it's
fun work Rex
[Music]
get away from your family this
Thanksgiving go see knives out in
theaters November 27 thank you so much
thank you ash
[Music]